well the current hype around artificial
intelligence has its origins in Silicon
Valley the technology and its
applications have been quietly coming of
age in some unexpected places
chondheim is the tech capital of Norway
home to a major university startups and
the start of our project on AI pretty
much everyone agrees AI is going to
transform Society including the jobs we
do but how far and how fast is that
going to happen
so we set ourselves the challenge of
seeing if we can get an AI to do my job
and I've come to Trondheim to meet
someone who can help us answer that
question it's
Chris is a YouTuber and coder who's been
experimenting with how to automate tasks
with the latest AIS like the leading
language model chat GPT I was quite
surprised that am I only the one using
this because I felt it's really
increased my productivity anyone can
prompt chat GPT to write a news report
but we wanted to do what others haven't
done and make the AI prompt itself to be
the journalist
Chris built our AI reporter on a
backbone of python computer code and
chat GPT
it gathers story ideas using a crawler
software that scans the web for the
latest news and video
to simulate the thought process of a
reporter to chat GPT agents work
together first an AI reporter pitches
what it thinks are the best stories then
an AI editor critiques the reporter's
work the AO reporter can then suggest
interviewees and generates an image
before writing an article and producing
a TV report
with a few taps our new recruit gets to
work
it's gonna create eight different ideas
so we can probably see those ideas
popping up soon
yeah you can see it is here now so we
have we're trying to fill up the Synergy
between the editor And the reporter
so that is the basic idea here
the first story it came up with was
about the impact of rising interest
rates on homeowners not bad but not very
original so we ran it again
this is a very polite editor here all of
your ideas are compelling report AI
reporter I think the story entitled
impact of heat waves on UK Public Health
well it's pretty relevant yeah yes
so we kind of want some data to back
that up okay and we can see some of the
results here 2019 UK Heat Wave and
effects on Hospital emissions so there's
some pretty bold claims in the article
about the increasing heat waves the
direct link to increase you know illness
and debt can we take those as fact uh no
you really shouldn't do that because the
model is kind of trained on that it
always wants to give a good response
right most of our ai's pitches were
pretty sensible a few definitely not in
a later run of our model it had an idea
based on a real event a milk Lorry crash
on the m6 but its story and AI generated
images claimed scientists had
subsequently discovered spilled milk
made roads safer we could find no such
evidence but if you can't really find a
good response it's always gonna make
something up that is kind of what we
call hallucinations
and in my business what you call
misinformation or lying yeah especially
okay next our AI reporter identifies
experts to interview and compose these
questions to them it could email its
interviewees directly but we decided
they may not welcome an unsolicited
approach from an AI so we sent its
emails ourselves
now about 20 minutes after we set it
running a news article is ready this is
it Heatwave havoc
unraveling the UK's escalating Health
crisis amid Rising temperatures
our AI reporter's next task is creating
an image for its article
but I don't think it's this Sky News
ready no I wouldn't say it'd probably be
a little bit too Fantastical and also
the sun looks a bit more like a nuclear
weapon going on but it's got the right
idea and certainly shimmering Heat going
on there okay but perhaps it's toughest
challenge is producing a TV report and
once it got the reporters saying the
reporter stands in a cityscape showing
London under a clear hot sky and a
reporter says as climate change remains
unabated being prepared is our best line
of defense against the blistering
onslaught of a hotter future wow its
ability to write short Punchy sentences
suggest where pictures should go the
fact the pictures are relevant to what's
going on that's that surprised me yeah I
think it's kind of looked at when it was
trained it kind of read thousands of
different TV news scripts yeah and it
tries to just emulate what I learned
from that we associate like this with
hotter dry countries on our own back in
London the next task is to use different
types of AI and a human volunteer to
give our reporter a personality
our producer Hannah lending her face and
voice to train an avatar
I have been trained using a four minute
video
pretty convincing to me
a few days later our reporter has a
Persona now that process is complete I
can say whatever text you type in All
That Remains is to feed our Avatar the
AI reporter's script
so has our experiment worked in my next
report we'll put that to the test is a
collection of AIS without real awareness
or the ability to think simply not up to
the task or have I done myself out of a
job I'm pretty impressed
Tom Clark Sky News
I think it's full of me